unlock the secrets of your family
history with my Heritage the number one
family history service in Europe with
more than 19 billion records at your
fingertips and AI powered tools to
enhance and animate your old family
photos my Heritage is the perfect way to
explore your past more on them in a bit
for five years senator Joseph McCarthy
was one of the most influential
politicians in America based primarily
on his Assurance as the public that
there was a vast communist conspiracy to
undermine the American way of life that
spies had infiltrated even the highest
levels of government and that only he
was brave enough and smart enough to
stop them while most people didn't
realize at the time however was that
this was a reputation built entirely on
lies his investigations produced little
evidence of Espionage instead accusing
people based on past associations family
histories or aspects of their private
lives thousands lost their jobs or at
their names dragged through the mud most
of whom were apparently loyal Americans
who had done nothing wrong it has become
known as McCarthyism a toxic mixture of
character assassination accusations made
without evidence and Reliance on Gossip
to ruin people perceive achieved as a
threat for McCarthy this extended to
anyone that opposed him on anything his
political enemies were subjected to
insults ridicule and allegations that
they were part of the Communist plot he
was a master of utilizing the media
obsessed with headlines and attention
moving from one fabrication to the next
faster than they could be refuted even
many members of his own party eventually
became fed up with him and worked
together with their opposition to bring
him down but the legacy of Joe McCarthy
has a Long Reach and the country is
still feeling its effects today
thank you foreign
Joseph Raymond McCarthy was born on a
farm in Central Wisconsin on November 14
1908. initially dropping out of school
at the age of 14 he later re-enrolled at
age 20 and eventually graduated from
Marquette University with a law degree
he first won elected office in 1939
becoming a circuit court judge McCarthy
proved to be a masterful campaigner
making an effort to visit the homes of
every potential voter later sending them
personal notes recounting their talks
and having a knack for remembering names
and faces he practically oozed charm and
Charisma though he wasn't above
muckraking even back then one of his
campaign planks was attacking his
incumbent opponent's age and the amount
of time it spent on the bench McCarthy
never intended to remain a judge for
long he had higher political Ambitions
when the U.S entered World War II he was
exempt from military service but
recognized that serving in uniform would
help with this future political
aspirations he joined the Marine Corps
primarily serving as an intelligence
briefing officer for a dive bombing
Squadron he never saw combat but
volunteered to serve as a rear Gunner on
several missions on one occasion he
delighted in using The Dauntless dive
bombers tail Mountain machine gun to
riddle the palm trees and empty ocean
with bullets earning the nickname
tailgunner Joe apparently McCarthy never
realized that the nickname was luckily
invented as a way to mock him because he
embraced it his Marine Corps career
would later cause controversy as
McCarthy would later embellish his
military service while on the campaign
Trail he played up his war wound which
was actually a broken ankle suffered in
a fall that wasn't combat related and he
inflated the number of combo missions
he'd served in in order to get himself
awarded the distinguished flying cross
and the air medal McCarthy returned to
Wisconsin after leaving the Marine Corps
in 1945 and immediately began preparing
to challenge for the Republican
nomination for Senate in the next year's
election his opponent was incumbent
Robert LaFollette Jr one of the Elder
Statesman of Wisconsin politics so it
seemed the little known McCarthy had an
uphill battle for the nomination but
McCarthy won after a campaign marked by
ugly personal attacks made against
LaFollette combined with McCarthy's
unique brand of retail campaigning that
is selling himself as a brand sort of
like a company would sell a product
McCarthy 38 was now the youngest senator
in Washington
Senator McCarthy showed little interest
in the day-to-day functions that made up
the majority of the job of being a
member of Congress while McCarthy liked
most of all was attention especially
political rallies attended by cheering
supporters and newspaper headlines what
he needed was a winning issue that he
could attached his name to something
that would cause people to pay attention
to him that also suited his unique
personality and brand after three mostly
undistinguished years in the Senate he
eventually settled almost by accident on
communism by 1950 fear of Communism was
widespread the Soviet Union had quickly
established itself as the US's Chief
rival for Global influence closing an
iron curtain around its eastern European
satellite States attempting to force the
Western allies out of Berlin through a
blockade and successfully exploding
their first atomic bomb in 1949. at the
same time America was rocked by Mao
zedong's Victory and the Chinese Civil
War setting up a communist government
while the Western nation-backed
nationalist government was forced into
Exile on Taiwan in June 1950 communist
North Korea invaded its Southern
neighbor starting a war which would
eventually really see a U.S led Alliance
fighting the Chinese to a bloody
stalemate on the peninsula it seemed
like communism which was apparently
diametrically opposed to everything
Americans stood for it was on the
upswing everywhere this fear of
Communism abroad was coupled with an
even more intense fear of Communism at
home fear of the red staging a similar
takeover to the one in Russia had
already caused a Red Scare in the U.S
during the first world war which saw
hundreds of people rounded up and
deported because of their suspected
links to left-win organizations plotting
social Revolution now America always
poised for a second even bigger red
scared this one penetrating every aspect
of American political life and Joe
McCarthy would soon Place himself at the
very center of it in a speech given in
February 1950 in Wheeling West Virginia
McCarthy claimed that the U.S state
Department was infested with Communists
waving around a piece of paper that he
said was a list of 205 members of the
Communist Party currently working there
the news reverberated around the country
like a Thunderclap confirming the
Public's worst fears that there were
communist agents in the government
either spying for the Soviets or
plotting the downfall of U.S democracy
Now supplied with the headlines and
attention he craved McCarthy or went on
to expand upon his allegations despite
privately admitting to not knowing
anything about communism beforehand this
was his ticket to the big time and he
knew it he ended up never publicly
showing his list of 205 Communists at
State changing the number repeatedly
down to 57 a few days later and up to 81
a few days after that nor would he say
where the list had come from historians
believed that he pruned his list from an
earlier list compiled for a House of
Representatives committee by a former
FBI agent that was tasked with finding
flaws in the state Department's security
screenings of employees most of those
flagged as security risks were not
associated with Communism they were
labeled such because of other so-called
weaknesses of character like engaging in
extramarital Affairs or public
drunkenness others had been members of
communist organizations back in the
1930s but had since renounced or they
were related to someone who had
previously been a member but this didn't
stop McCarthy from not only claiming
that the whole lot of them were
card-carrying Communists but that they
were also disloyal agents working
against America if you're curious to
explore your family's history and
uncover hidden stories then you should
definitely check out today's sponsor
myheritage myheritage is the number one
family history service in Europe and
it's an incredible genealogy platform to
build your family tree and discover your
Origins they've got more than 19 billion
records that you can search for for your
old family records that you probably
thought were lost to time I've already
made some amazing discoveries about my
own family I've gone back and found like
military records from the first world
war immigration records from like the
1850s I found a census report that like
my great Grandad had signed like talking
about his family and what they did and
stuff it's in his handwriting like a
scan of it it's been pretty amazing and
not only is the information easily
accessible but my Heritage provides a
platform for restoring colorizing
enhancing and even animating your old
photos plus with 90 million users around
the world actively building their family
trees you can connect with people who
share your ancestry my Heritage also
offers an incredible AI time machine
allowing you to see yourself as a
historical figure you just have to
upload a few recent photos of yourself
and wow they have it you in history look
at these b-rolls on the screen now of uh
some that I did to myself you could get
a 14 day free trial to experience all
the amazing features that my Heritage
has to offer plus if you decide to
continue your subscription after your
trial ends you can use the special link
in the description below for a 50
discount and now back to today's video
because his accusations resulted in the
creation of a senate investigatory panel
chaired by Millard Tidings of Maryland
the tidings committee provided a public
forum for McCarthy to flesh out his
charges publicly naming nine people he
claimed were Soviet agents the Senator's
accusations were thought by others to be
poorly prepared and presented and the
committee ended up ruling that he hadn't
substantiated any of them but McCarthy
wasn't really trying his case in the
Senate he was doing it in the court of
public opinion and out in the
countryside he was finding great success
what McCarthy was doing was spraying his
accusatory machine gun in all directions
hoping to hit upon a major case like
arga hiss a diplomat who had been
accused of Espionage the year before
helping to make the career of then
Congressman Richard Nixon in the process
it didn't really matter to him if he hit
innocent people caught in the crossfire
he would privately justify by claiming
it was in the interest of National
Security all nine of those he publicly
accused in the tidings committee
hearings would have their careers
negatively impacted some never working
in government again McCarthy lied a lot
he lied about where it gotten
information from what one of his targets
said or did his office would alter
documents or photographs to make them
more inflammatory and he was able to get
away with it for years without anyone
successfully being able to call him out
on it there were several reasons for
this and the biggest being that McCarthy
was able to skillfully manipulate the
dominant media of the period newspapers
to his Advantage he timed press
conferences to coincide with timed that
newspapers printed afternoon or evening
editions meaning editors would have to
rush to put his latest Outburst in print
without being able to fact check it or
put it in context when someone owed
refute his accusations it usually came a
few days later and ended up on page 14.
meanwhile the front page was covering
another McCarthy headline as he smoothly
moved on from one target to the next
never publicly admitting that he was
wrong about anything the sheer amount of
copy devoted to McCarthy gained him
support from the public the oh where
there's smoke there must be fire fallacy
this was also in the pre Vietnam premium
Watergate era when the American public
had a hard time believing that someone
in a responsible position of power like
a member of Congress would knowingly
deceive them what made things worse is
that most of McCarthy's victims were
unable to sue him for defamation or
libel since speeches given on the senate
floor are protected by the Constitution
almost from the moment he got there Joe
McCarthy was disliked by many of his
Senate colleagues the man was Brash and
rude and public and in private
especially when someone wouldn't give
him his way he had little respect but
the Senate as an institution and
bureaucrats had no patience to wait for
his turn for committee assignments or
for debate on legislation refused to
take advice from anybody but they
largely put up with him in the first few
years of his notoriety because they were
afraid of what he could do to them in
regardless of the 1950 election McCarthy
campaigned widely on behalf of
candidates that he supported giving
speeches to adoring crowds about the
evils of Communism and the shortcomings
of various elected officials opposed to
him he was even more prominent in the
1952 campaign giving the keynote speech
at the Republican National Convention
modern analysis shows that it is
unlikely that McCarthy gave Republican
candidates much of a bump in either of
these elections that they would have
likely won without him but there was a
perception at the time that he had a
vast Grassroots support network across
the country that he was unleashing on
people who crossed him based on the poor
electoral showings of outspoken McCarthy
opponents like Senator Tidings who lost
his re-election bid in 1950. McCarthy
himself believed he had the power to
play kingmaker in Congress and wasn't
afraid to use threats of electoral ruin
on his opponent to get them to yield
McCarthy's threats extended beyond the
halls of Congress he waged war against
anyone who said anything negative about
him at all he made up insulting
nicknames he used in public for people
or organizations that opposed him
calling the anti-mccarthy Milwaukee
Journal the Milwaukee urinal he
attempted to exert influence on the FCC
to silence his critics who gave as good
as they got labeling the senator a dime
store Rose Pierre and a mediocre lawyer
with an easy conscience the culture of
fear that McCarthy helped to create
caused a dangerous reaction the
ratcheting up of the so-called Security
State multiple Congressional panels as
well as investigative bodies at the
state and local level and within
government organizations now saw
communist infiltrators everywhere
thousands of people were investigated
and had their careers tarnished by the
merest hint of an association with any
group perceived as being too
left-leaning many oh were dismissed from
government service based merely on the
threat that they might be communist
sympathizers using the most spurious of
evidence to justify it people were being
purged not because of their actions but
because of their beliefs their suspected
beliefs or the suspected beliefs of
someone they were related to The Purge
was extended to include homosexual men
working in government the so-called
lavender scare the official reason for
this purge was that closeted gay men
were vulnerable to be being blackmailed
but whether or not that was true they
were still an easy target that was sure
to have public appeal McCarthy who faced
accusations of homosexuality himself
because of his status as a lifelong
bachelor until his marriage in 1953
seemed to take vindictive pleasure in
rooting out what he called nests of sex
perverts
with the Republicans gaining the Senate
majority in the 1952 election McCarthy
now at his own committee that he could
use to continue investigations of
suspected Communists the permanent
subcommittee on investigations or PSI he
hired a 26 year old lawyer from New York
named Roy Cohn to serve as psi's Chief
counsel and over the next year the two
would form a close working relationship
McCarthy growing to rely more and more
on Cohn to the point that it eventually
destroyed him McCarthy's next Target was
the voice of America the state-owned
radio station that broadcast into
foreign countries particularly behind
the Iron Curtain McCarthy claimed that
two broadcast Towers recently opened
were deficient and he suspected to be
the result of deliberate Sabotage by
communist agents inside VOA when that's
accomplished nothing except the
destruction of morale within the agency
McCarthy moved on to the overseas
libraries program maintained by the
International Information agency Roy
Cohn went on a much published Whirlwind
tour of Europe examining the card
catalogs of the libraries looking for
books written by supposedly pro-con
authors McCarthy presented a list of
titles he said should be removed and the
state department complied some libraries
actually burned the books in question
prompting a quick back hurdle by the
administration though not by McCarthy
lest America find itself compared to
Nazi Germany on the subject of
censorship but McCarthy's biggest target
soon became the United States Army
McCarthy had always held a grudge
against the Army going back to his days
in the Marine Corps he was also a
growing critic of President Dwight D
Eisenhower who had been the top Army
General in Europe during World War II
and many wondered if his sudden Zeal for
finding Communists in the Army had
anything to do with trying to tweak
Eisenhower's nose in the fall of 1953
McCarthy's committee investigated Fort
Monmouth home of the signal Corps
claiming that the sensitive
Communications laboratory there had a
communist spy ring within it when that
didn't pan out McCarthy then turned his
attention to the case of Irving Paris a
dentist that had been drafted into the
army and had refused to answer questions
on an army loyalty questionnaire
resulting in some of his superiors
questioning whether he was a communist
McCarthy said personally thought so and
dragged Perez and his commanding officer
Brigadier General Ralph's Wicker in
front of his committee to grill them his
treatment of his wicker was particularly
bad at one point yelling that he had the
intelligence of a five-year-old and
wasn't fit to wear the army uniform this
grave insult to a man who'd received the
Silver Star for his heroism on the
beaches of Normandy was the last straw
of her Army secretary Robert T Stevens
who decided to strike back with a little
dirt of his own G David shine shine a
wealthy heir to her hotel Fortune was on
McCarthy's investigatory staff as an
unpaid consultant he and Roy Cohn were
close friends traveling around Europe
together and frequently going out
drinking in the fall of 1953 shine was
drafted into the army Cohn immediately
attempted to use his influence to
attempt to get special treatment for his
friend from pressing for a commission as
an officer to trying to get him light
duties and extra Liberty passes Cohn
reportedly stated that he would wreck
the Army and destroy the career of
Stevens if his demands weren't met
Stevens surely would tat it backing from
the Y White House made a public
accusation that McCarthy and Cohen
attempted to improperly influence the
Army to gain special treatment for shine
and the war was on
the Army McCarthy hearings which lasted
from April to June 1954. had America
riveted from the start it was one of the
first major government hearings covered
by the new medium of television with ABC
covering what turned out to be a
three-ring circus gavel to gavel this
was the first time most people had seen
McCarthy work and by and large they
weren't impressed his Bluster his
bullying tactics his name-calling were
all on full display he had a
particularly acrimonious relationship
with the Army's lead Council Boston
attorney Joseph Welch the decisive
moment came on day 30 of the hearings
when McCarthy attempted to discredit
Welch by revealing that one of the
attorneys at his Law Firm had once
belonged to the National lawyers Guild
which oh was at the time labeled by the
FBI as being a Communist front
organization Welch replied that he
already knew about this which is why he
asked the man to recuse himself from the
case when McCarthy continued to attempt
to smear the man Welch lost his temper
assassinate this lad further senator
look look you have done enough when his
rebuke of McCarthy was finished the
gallery burst into Applause when the
hearings finished the committee assigns
no blame to McCarthy blaming Karen alone
for improper influence he was forced to
resign rather than be fired but the
public relations hit the McCarthy took
from the hearings as well as an
investigative piece done around the same
time by celebrated journalist Edward R M
Morrow was severe then the shocking news
the popular Wyoming Senator Lester hunt
had shot himself in his office came out
it would be revealed later than McCarthy
and his Senate allies had attempted a
black male hunt by threatening to reveal
details of his son's recent arrest
during a homosexuality sting in
Washington if he didn't resign his
office this wasn't even the first
suicide that could be attributed to
McCarthy an engineer at Voice of America
to spawned and that he would be publicly
smeared in front of McCarthy's committee
threw himself in front of a truck his
Senate colleagues had finally had enough
of Joe McCarthy in December 1954 they
voted 67-22 to censor him one of only
nine senators in history to be handed
the harsh just rebuke that body can give
to one of its members short of expulsion
his influence evaporated almost
overnight journalists no longer paid
attention to him refusing to cover his
speeches or print them on the front page
his Senate colleagues shunned him when
he gave a speech in Congress it was to
an almost empty chamber and those who
were there made it a point to not pay
attention to him he was no longer
welcome at the white house or at the
homes of most of Washington's power
Brokers his speaking invitations all
dried up the few he did give oh was
sparsely attended certainly the
Republicans wanted him nowhere near the
campaign Trail in 1954 and 1956 he was
persona non grata as barra's
endorsements went McCarthy became
despondent rarely attending Senate
sessions and blaming everyone but
himself for the loss of his reputation
he had always been a drinker during his
time in the Senate but as alcohol
consumption got really bad after his
censure he also had a worsening
dependency on morphine few people felt
badgering had after all brought it upon
himself even a right up until the end if
he simply apologized toned down his
rhetoric or admitted to making some
Stakes it's unlikely he would have been
censored instead ah one of the things he
ended up getting Centered for was
verbally abusing the committee put
together to decide whether or not he
should be censored there's no telling
whether or not McCarthy would have won
re-election to a third term in 1958
because he died before the election on
May the 2nd 1957. he was only 48 years
old and while the official cause of
death according to Bethesda naval
hospital was hepatitis pretty much
everyone including his closest friends
believed that he drank himself to death
after the fall of McCarthy the United
States began reevaluating its Security
State realizing too late how badly
they'd reacted between ten thousand and
twelve thousand people lost their jobs
because of suspected dies to subversive
elements and hundreds were imprisoned at
least 5 000 federal workers lost their
jobs after being suspected of or being
outed as homosexual and thousands more
suffered persecution or blackmail by
their co-workers even once the Red Scare
died down the lavender scare continued
the state department admitted during its
official apology in 2017 that they were
investigating their employees sexual
orientations as late as the 1990s
McCarthyism is still used today to refer
to public figures who engage in
character assassination and
unsubstantiated accusations in order to
smear their opponents celebrated pieces
of media including the novel Fahrenheit
451 and the play and later movie The
Crucible were clear references to the
excesses of McCarthyism however
Americans for the most part have elected
to forget about the MacArthur era
instead remembering the 1950s as a time
of economic Prosperity the rise of car
culture and the childhood of the Baby
Boomers however the legacy of Joe
McCarthy extends well past that sad
period of history and on into today most
notably Roy Cohn the ill-fated McCarthy
associate went on to have a long
controversial legal career in New York
City including serving as the personal
attorney to Donald Trump who considered
him a mentor nor was McCarthyism simply
an isolated case of Hysteria as
historians can cite similar cases going
back to the Salem Witch Trials of the
17th century all the way up to the
satanic daycare Panic of the 1980s and
even Beyond comparison to McCarthyism
have been drawn to the early years of
the war on terror after 9 11 when a
scared public allowed its government to
do things that it would later regret Joe
McCarthy wasn't the first of his kind
and he certainly wasn't the last but
what etches his unfortunate place in
history was that he was one of the first
to win Mass Appeal by suggesting that
there were elements within the American
government that couldn't be trusted that
they were plotting to destroy the nation
from within a scene that has existed
within extremist elements of American
politics ever